I'm rich hall and I'm Julie Pyatt
welcome to our home and to our family a
lifestyle we call the Platt power way
today I'm a recognized ultra endurance
athlete a number one best-selling author
podcast host a public speaker a wellness
evangelist as well as a husband and a
father of four but it wasn't always this
way just eight years ago I was
overworked out of shape more importantly
lethargic and unenthusiastic about my
life a health scare on the eve of my
40th birthday made me realize not only
that I needed to change but that I
wanted to change first time that I
experienced the healing power of food
was when I received what I like to call
a gift a golf ball-sized cyst in the
front of my neck and I healed it through
the use of Ayurvedic herbs and a
plant-based diet
Julie's experience and more importantly
her example had a profound impact on me
and the truth is everything changed when
I decided to adopt a plant-based diet
it didn't just save my life it gave me
an entirely new one
the extra pounds melted away my skin
cleared up my sleep improved and most
importantly my energy level skyrocketed
my precious enthusiasm for life restored
people say you can't live you can't be
healthy let alone be successful as an
athlete on a plant-based diet I'm living
proof that that is completely false and
Men's Fitness Magazine agreed when it
named me one of the 25 fittest men on
the planet I chronicled my personal
journey in my first book finding ultra
the plant power wave picks up we're
finding ultra leaves off every day we
get asked what do you guys eat where you
get your protein and especially how am I
going to feed my kids healthy
plant-based meals so the plant power way
is our answer to these questions and so
much more 300 pages 120 delicious easy
to prepare recipes covering breakfast
lunch dinner smoothies juices dessert
snacks and my favorite sauces all the
recipes in the plant power way are
incredibly easy and simple to prepare
it's a compass to guide you and your
children beyond the plate or as Julie
likes to say beyond the kale gathering
the family around food is a very central
experience of life food is a powerful
energy and transformation begins and
ends with what we put in our mouths and
what I've discovered is that it's just
not that hard it doesn't have to be
expensive or time-consuming or even
inconvenient
it's a gorgeous educational and
aspirational lifestyle guy designed for
the modern family you can begin where
you are because it's not a diet it's a
lifestyle it's about the journey not the
destination
this evolution revolution is real so
take our hand and make the leap because
there is a better way it's called the
plant power way
you